tengo aquí una matriz y lo que quiero
hacer es escribirla en su forma
escalonada reducida y hemos hecho eso un
montón de veces ya y pues lo que hacemos
es hacer operaciones elementales
operaciones de fila donde sumamos sólo
resta vamos una fila a otra fila en
todas esas cosas pero bueno lo que yo
quiero hacer en este vídeo es que veamos
que todas esas operaciones de fila se
pueden ver como operaciones lineales
sobre los vectores columna de esta
matriz porque hay sobre estos vectores y
déjame te enseño todo esto haciendo un
ejemplo ok entonces queremos escribir
esta matriz en su forma escalonada
reducida entonces lo primero que vamos a
hacer es dejar la primera fila tal cual
como está o sea aquí vamos a tener uno
menos uno
y sabes que de una vez vamos a hacer la
transformación lineal ok lo que estamos
diciendo es que hay una transformación
lineal
llamémosle t 1 que va a mandar a
vectores columna o sea cada uno de estos
vectores que es un vector columna y esta
transformación va a mandar a estos
vectores columna en otros vectores pero
además va a ser una transformación
lineal ok y como queremos transformar a
esta matriz a su forma escalonada
reducida pues necesitamos que esta
entrada sigue siendo un 1 entonces pues
podemos empezar por dejar esta primera
fila en su lugar ok a 1 la vamos a dejar
como a 1 y aquí ya la tenemos escrita
después queremos que esta entrada se
transforme en un 0 y qué podemos hacer
para hacer eso pues a esta segunda fila
le sumaríamos la primera fila y con eso
ya aquí nos queda un 0 entonces pues
hagamos eso así es que la segunda
vamos a dejar en su lugar pero le vamos
a sumar la primera fila entonces a cada
uno de estos vectores columna dejamos la
segunda entrada en su lugar y le sumamos
la primera entrada que hay aquí menos
uno más uno eso son cero luego aquí a
este vector también le aplicamos la
transformación entonces 2 más menos 1
eso es uno y aquí 3 más menos 1 esos son
dos muy bien ya terminamos con la
segunda fila ahora queremos que esta
entrada también sea 0 y para hacer eso
generalmente tomaríamos la tercera y la
y le restaría mos la primera fila
entonces a la tercera entrada le vamos a
dejar en su lugar a 3
y le vamos a restar la primera entrada
- a
aplicando la transformación a cada
vector columna lo que tenemos es a 3
menos a 1 o sea 11 eso es cero después
aquí tenemos la tercera entrada
1 - la primera entrada o sea 1 - menos
uno eso es uno más uno o sea dos y
después cuatro menos menos uno o sea 415
y esta es una transformación lineal y
todas las transformaciones lineales se
pueden escribir como un producto de una
matriz por el vector que por el vector
en el cual estamos evaluando la
transformación de uno de equis evaluado
en x se puede escribir como una matriz
llamamos le llamamos la matriz ese que
está multiplicando al vector en el cual
estamos hablando la transformación ok y
como encontramos esta matriz s pues lo
único que tenemos que hacer es tomar la
matriz identidad déjame la escribo por
acá
y aplicarle la transformación de uno a
cada uno de los vectores columna de la
matriz identidad ok entonces para
encontrar este aplicamos esta
transformación a cada uno de los
vectores columna de la matriz identidad
ok entonces aplicando la transformación
de uno a cada uno de los vectores
columna de la matriz identidad tenemos
que la primera entrada siempre se queda
igual ok a uno lo está mandando a
exactamente a uno aunque entonces esta
entrada se queda igual 1 después de aquí
el 0 también se queda igual al igual que
este 0 ok estamos aplicando esta
transformación de 1 simultáneamente a
estos tres vectores entonces nos fijamos
en la segunda entrada del vector columna
y ésta nos lo está mandando a la segunda
entrada más la primera entrada
entonces para este vector columna esta
transformación que está mandando la
segunda entrada a 0 +1 0 +1 es 1
ok aplicándole al vector de la derecha
nos queda 10 también es uno y después x
0 0 es cero y ahora de uno nos manda a
la última entrada de cada uno de los
vectores columna a la última entrada
menos la primera entrada aunque entonces
para este vector columna nos lo está
mandando a 0 -1 aunque yo sea menos 1 y
luego aquí es 0 - 0 0 y 10
y este vector columna nos lo está
mandando a este vector columna o sea
aquí lo que tenemos
este 1 d
0 0
y luego tenemos aquí otro vector que es
el vector de 1 b 0 1 0 y el último
vector columna este 1 de 0 0
este vector columna es tal cual de uno
de 100
y bueno esta matriz que damos que le
íbamos a llamar ese rey esta matriz es
la matriz de esta transformación de uno
entonces si nosotros creamos otra matriz
una matriz donde nuestros vectores
columnas sean s aplicado a el vector
1 - 1 1 o sea los vectores columna de la
matriz
y el segundo vector columna es la
multiplicación de nuestra matriz s por
el segundo vector columna b
ósea
por menos 121 y finalmente efe de menos
entonces por un lado estamos aplicándole
a cada uno de los vectores columna de a
la transformación que es multiplicar el
vector por la matriz s y esta
transformación es tal cual esta
transformación de uno que es justo lo
que le hicimos a la matriz a para que se
convirtiera en esta otra matriz que
estaba un poquito más escalonada
entonces tal cual esta matriz al
multiplicar cada uno de estos vectores
por s lo que nos va a quedar es
exactamente la misma matriz de acá y por
otro lado nosotros sabemos que si
multiplicamos cada uno de los vectores
columna de una matriz por exactamente la
misma matriz en este caso la matriz ese
entonces lo que lo que tenemos realmente
la multiplicación de la matriz s por la
matriz a ok déjame lo escribo un poco
más abajo esto de acá es igual a la
matriz s
11 - 10 10
es la matriz que representa la
transformación de uno y éstos son los
vectores columna de la matriz y la
matriz
- 11 menos 121 menos 134 ok para dejarlo
claro esta matriz ya que es la matriz s
y esta matriz ya que es la matriz
y la multiplicación de los dos es
exactamente igual a esta matriz que
teníamos por acá déjame la copio
entonces esta matriz es el producto de
la matriz s por la matriz o sea esta
matriz es f
y estoy haciendo todo esto solo para
recordarte que cada vez que haces una de
esas operaciones de fila
cada una de estas operaciones de file o
sea de sumarle una fila a la otra
multiplicada por una escalada y todas
esas cosas en realidad todo eso es
equivalente a tomar la matriz a y
multiplicarla por otra matriz que denota
la transformación que le estamos
aplicando a cada uno de los vectores
columnas hicimos todo esto solo para
recordarte que cada vez que hacemos una
operación de fila lo que estamos
haciendo es aplicarle una transformación
lineal a cada uno de los vectores
columna de la matriz a y que además eso
es equivalente a multiplicar toda la
matriz a por la matriz de la
transformación en este caso averiguamos
cuál era exactamente esa matriz s que
representa esta transformación en uno
que hace estas operaciones de fila pero
para cualquier operación de fila tenemos
una matriz similar a ésta que si la
multiplicamos por la matriz a nos queda
tal cual la matriz a con la operación de
fila ya hecha
y todo esto nos da una muy buena idea
bueno pero primero hay que terminar de
transformar esta matriz a su forma
escalonada reducida y para eso
necesitamos espacio
entonces a esta matriz a esta
transformación la primera que hicimos
pues mejor llamémosle ese 1 para poder
usar ese y ahora vamos con el siguiente
conjunto de operaciones de filas
en esta ocasión vamos a dejar la fila de
en medio tal cual como esta
y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es que
estas dos entradas sean 0 y para hacer
eso pues a la primera y la vamos a
sumarle a la segunda fila entonces
tenemos aquí 10
y después menos 110
- 12 eso es 1 y a esta tercera fila
vamos a restarle dos veces la segunda
fila para que nos quede aquí un solo
entonces tenemos cero menos dos veces
cero
2 - 2 veces 12 - 2 por 1 o sea 0
5 - dos veces 2 o sea 5 menos 4 1
entonces qué es lo que acabo de hacer a
cada uno de estos vectores columna les
aplique una transformación que vamos a
llamarle la transformación 2 que es la
transformación
2 y bueno esa transformación 2 voy a ser
una situación un poquito distinta vamos
a ponerle aquí que está evaluando en
director
y este vector columna digamos que es x 1
x 2 x 3
y bueno que es lo que hicimos con estos
vectores columna
pues a la segunda entrada siempre la
dejamos en su lugar o sea esta fila está
exactamente igual entonces al x2 a la
segunda entrada la vamos a dejar tal
cual como está y después en la primera
entrada lo que hicimos fue tomar la
primera entrada y sumarle además la
segunda entrada entonces aquí tomamos la
primera entrada y la dejamos así pero
además le sumamos la segunda entrada y
qué es lo que hicimos con la última
entrada de cada vector columna pues lo
que hicimos fue agarrar esa misma
entrada a la entrada x 3 pero restarle
dos veces la segunda entrada
ok entonces aquí tenemos escribir menos
2 x 2 y bueno esta es una transformación
lineal por lo tanto puede ser
representada por una matriz y esta
transformación es igual a tomar esa
matriz que le vamos a llamar ese 2 que
la representa y multiplicarlo por el
vector x 1 x 2 y x
entonces toda esta matriz quién es pues
es el resultado de multiplicar esta
segunda matriz que está representando a
esta transformación por esta otra matriz
ahora ya habíamos quedado que esta otra
matriz de hecho lo pintamos con morado
esta otra matriz es ese 1 por a entonces
esta matriz de acá tiene que ser ese 2
por toda esta matriz que es ese 1
y bueno si sacamos cuál es la
multiplicación de ese 2 por ese 1 y
bueno si lo hacemos como antes y
encontramos cuál es la matriz ese 2 y la
multiplicamos por la matriz ese 1 que ya
tenemos aquí abajo pues podríamos llegar
desde la matriz a hasta esta otra matriz
simplemente multiplicando por esta otra
matriz que nos da la multiplicación de
estas dos matrices
pero todavía no terminamos de
transformar esta matriz para que quede
como una matriz escalonada reducida
entonces vamos a seguir haciendo
transformaciones tenemos un cero aquí y
un 0 acá y esta fila ya está tal cual
como queremos que se quede así es que
vamos a dejarla igual
y aquí a esta fila pues para que aquí
nos quede un 0 vamos a reemplazar esta
fila por esta fila menos dos veces esta
fila aunque entonces 0 menos dos veces
cero sigue siendo 0 1 - dos veces 0 es 1
y ahora sí
2 - 2 veces 1 eso es
ahora para que aquí haya un 0 tenemos
que reemplazar esta primera fila por la
primera fila menos la última fila
entonces 1 0 es 1 000 y 1 menos 10 y ya
llegamos a la matriz identidad pero
tenemos que escribir cuál es la
transformación que usamos para ir de
esta matriz a esta matriz y pues vamos a
escribirla por acá de 3 de x 1 x 2 x 3
pues aquí lo que hicimos fue dejar la
última fila tal cual o sea que el x3 lo
vamos a mandar al x 3 la segunda fila la
reemplazamos por la segunda y la menos
dos veces la tercera fila y la primera
fila la reemplazamos por la primera fila
menos una sola vez la tercera fila y
como ésta es una transformación lineal
entonces tiene asociada una matriz que
la representa lo vamos a llamar la
matriz s 3 y entonces esta matriz de acá
la podemos obtener multiplicando esa
matriz s 3 por esta matriz y esta matriz
será ese 2 por ese 1 por a
y bueno entonces lo que obtuvimos al
transformar esta matriz a su forma
escalonada reducida fue exactamente
igual a la identidad y eso es muy
importante porque lo que nos dice tal
cual como ya lo hemos visto antes es que
si una matriz a la hora de transformarla
a su forma escalonada reducida nos da la
identidad entonces esa matriz es
invertible al igual que su
transformación lineal asociada
acuérdense que para cada matriz en este
caso es la matriz tenemos una
transformación lineal asociada entonces
no se llamémosle de 0 a 0 de un vector x
es igual a la transformación lineal que
nos da tomar la matriz a y multiplicarla
por el vector x que está es la
transformación lineal asociada a la
matriz y como la forma escalonada
reducida de la matriz a es la identidad
entonces esta transformación de 0
también es invertible
invertí bien
ahora en este vídeo algo muy interesante
paso ok
tomamos la matriz a y la transformamos a
su forma escalonada reducida haciendo
algunas operaciones de filas pero además
notamos que hacer esas operaciones de
fila es exactamente equivalente a tomar
la matriz a y multiplicarla por las
matrices s1 s2 y s3 ok entonces esta
multiplicación de la matriz a por estas
otras matrices nos queda exactamente
igual a la matriz identidad ahora por
otro lado tenemos aquí también que todas
las transformaciones que son invertibles
tienen a su transformación inversa y esa
transformación inversa justo lo que hace
es acá vector x
la matriz inversa de a por equis y la
matriz inversa de a es tal cual una
matriz que hace que la matriz inversa de
a x la matriz a nos queda exactamente
igual a la identidad entonces tenemos
aquí tres matrices que cuando las
multiplicamos por esta cosa que es la
misma que esta cosa nos da la identidad
y éste también cuando lo multiplicamos
por a nos da la identidad entonces esta
cosa de aquí esta multiplicación de tres
matrices tiene que ser la matriz a
inversa
si se acuerdan aquí hicimos todos los
cálculos para calcular cuál era la
matriz s 1
y podríamos hacer exactamente lo mismo
para calcular cuál es la matriz s 2 y
para calcular la matriz s 3 y entonces
lo único que tendríamos que hacer para
calcular la matriz inversa sería
multiplicar estas tres matrices y esto
pero de hecho podemos hacer algo todavía
más interesante
a ver qué pasa si tomamos la matriz
y ponemos a la derecha de la matriz a la
matriz identidad y después lo que
hacemos es a la matriz a aplicarle todo
es el primer conjunto de operaciones de
fila que era exactamente igual a
multiplicar a por la matriz s 1 y bueno
la aplicamos exactamente las mismas
operaciones de fila a la matriz
identidad entonces lo que nos va a
quedar de este lado es simplemente la
matriz s
1 sí porque aplicarle las operaciones de
fila a la matriz identidad es
exactamente igual a multiplicar ese 1
por la matriz y y cualquier matriz que
esté multiplicando la matriz y es tal
cual esa misma matriz bien entonces
después de aplicarle el primer conjunto
de operación de fila a la matriz
lo que hicimos fue aplicarle el segundo
conjunto y eso es equivalente a
multiplicar toda esta matriz por la
matriz ese 2
ok tomamos aquí
este 22 y la multiplicamos por la matriz
que ya teníamos o sea por ese 1 por a ok
entonces de este lado al aplicar estas
mismas operaciones de fila tenemos que
multiplicar también por la matriz s 2
este 2 por ese 1 por la identidad y
finalmente hacemos el tercer conjunto de
operaciones de fila y eso es equivalente
a multiplicar toda esta matriz que ya
tenemos por la matriz s 3 que representa
justo a la transformación que mueve las
filas de la forma en la que las movimos
entonces tenemos aquí ese 3 por ese 2
por ese 1
y de este lado también nos va a quedar
ese 3 por ese 2 por ese 1 por la
identidad
ahora como vimos aquí esta
multiplicación de matrices lo que nos da
es exactamente la identidad y que es lo
que nos va a dar esta multiplicación de
matrices que vamos a obtener de este
lado pues esto es exactamente igual a la
matriz
inversa y recuerda que cualquier cosa
que multiplicamos por la identidad nos
va a quedar exactamente ese cualquier
cosa entonces ya tenemos una forma
generalizada de encontrar la matriz
inversa dada una matriz invertible ok lo
que hacemos es tomar una matriz de
aumentada y para hacer esas matrices tal
cual lo que tenemos que hacer es poner
la matriz
y al lado de la matriz ponemos la matriz
identidad
y ya que tenemos nuestra matriz
aumentada nos fijamos en esta parte o
sea en la matriz hada y hacemos muchas
operaciones de fila hasta que
transformemos esta parte en la matriz
identidad pero cada una de las
operaciones de fila que le hagamos a
esta matriz también se las tenemos que
hacer a la matriz que nos queda aquí a
la derecha que en un inicio es la matriz
identidad entonces después de hacer
muchas operaciones de fila lo que
obtenemos es aquí la matriz identidad y
de este lado lo que vamos a obtener es
la matriz
inversa así es que este es un método muy
bueno y elegante para encontrar la
inversa de una matriz invertible y pues
vamos a verlo en el próximo vídeo vamos
a ver un ejemplo yo creo que vamos a
usar esta misma matriz con la que
empezamos y vamos a calcular
explícitamente usando este método
la matriz inversa